hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel i think this might be the
first video i've uploaded here where i
don't have my green screen up it's just
i mean i could set it up but i just i
won't be candid it does look like i'm in
a kitchen
i'm technically not it's just a studio
apartment and this webcam flattens
things so they feel
separate but they are right next to each
other so today i have some very exciting
news that i've been sitting on for a
while that i've been kind of dancing
around
um i guess we'll just get to it i'm very
stoked to be able to talk about this i
am in cyberpunk 2077.
this is why every time i've ever spoken
about this game
i've been like full disclosure very
biased where this game is concerned
not that i'm not anyway i've been a fan
of cd projekt red for such a long time
to the extent that i make
every character in every rpg that i play
look like geralt
the witcher 2 super underrated i feel
like the witcher 3 is appropriately
rated and i think it is
probably the best game of the previous
generation the witcher 2 though
play it beautiful work but then i'm also
such a big fan of the cyberpunk genre
and of the music and of the style and
the neon and i love all of it so
getting to be a part of this is like one
of the most exciting things that has
happened to me
i'm happy to talk about like how it came
about and what it means
um i don't even know if my character is
named after me
but they certainly don't have my
personality
and i certainly have to do a lot of
acting
this one was hard so this is me here's
how i look hi
that's definitely my mouth and it's
definitely my nose
it's also my face shape they got my
freckles they even got that little mole
that i have on my cheek right here
my hair is naturally a different color i
don't have cybernetic arms in real life
don't buy the click bait i don't have
those arms it's so it's just so cool to
look at
um and if you can't tell from this image
i am allowed to tell you this i can't
actually talk to you guys about my quest
that's a spoiler i'm not allowed to go
into details about that because i am
an npc um with what i think is a pretty
dope quest
but worth noting i am only available in
the nomad playthrough
which is part of why i keep saying i'm
going to play as nomad
so you 100 will only find me in
the nomad life path it's so cool my god
so this conversation started back in
like 2018
um it was just as i was leaving ign
because of course while working at ign
as a games journalist there is no way
that i would have ever been in any video
game
i did record gears 5 and after party
both in 2018 and my first cyberpunk
session was
in 2019 and then again in early 2020 i
think it was like january this year
maybe so i did do two of those here in
la but yeah the conversation first
started uh back
in in they had a meeting with me in e3
and this is because i had had a
conversation with him about it even
earlier so i don't even know how far
back this goes it might be a while
but yeah at e3 i met with um the guy who
was my quest designer which was very
cool
they did ask me what kind of role that i
wanted to play and at first i was like
can you make me a dj
which is funny because i asked that
before i was a dj in afterparty
they didn't go with that obviously i'm a
nomad in a junkyard here
but yeah they they wrote my quest uh i
had to send them a bunch of
images basically stills so i wasn't
scanned into the game
they just modeled the 3d character based
off of my appearance uh i sent like full
body images
all of that stuff so that they had all
of my features i guess there's even like
i have this little freckle below my
belly button that they actually have on
there
i don't know if that's coincidence but i
do have that it's crazy
and then yeah went and recorded my vo um
some of the toughest vo i've done for
any game
even though the second session was
pretty short i felt like i walked out
like
exhausted but i'm not really allowed to
say more than that
so yeah this is just something that's so
surreal to me
so cool and also i love the way that it
ties into cyberpunk law i feel like
having people who are
digital creators then exist
in a game about a digital space where
the plot seems to be centered around
a digital chip that would grant you
immortality
is pretty meta i think it just really
suits
the game to have the cameos that it does
have i know it was just announced that
um
what's her name the one
grimes grimes it would be a disservice
to say the one who's with elon
i apologize grimes you're an independent
woman or whatever
i think she's in the game that was just
announced we'll move over grimes because
so am i
no it was really fun to do really fun to
work with the team they're so excited
and seem so passionate
um but i will say outside of you know my
quest
and i guess like the hands-on time that
i had with the game or like behind
closed doors demo
i don't know [ __ ] about this game
everything that i know
again aside from literally this one
quest is public they have not given me
any insight i don't have any insider
information
i guess i know how cd projekt right i
know what their format is
i know what script edits look like and
uh
their booth direction is like but i'm
not gonna talk about that
but otherwise uh you can't ask me any
questions that aren't already like
things i've already spoken about because
i honestly don't know anything this
doesn't mean i have any insider
information
of course just to preempt this i did
want to also say
no you dummies of course i'm not
reviewing the game when i got the chat
people kept being like you better not
review this game and i had to be like no
i haven't reviewed games here in two
years why did you think i was suddenly
gonna review this
technically they did pay me i have been
paid for my
services as voice actor here cd projekt
red
did pay me full disclosure
no issue disclosing that and i am yeah
so stoked to be a part of this
i wonder if i could pull off a cosplay
of myself
because that would rule but yes mostly
this is very exciting for me and also
very exciting to be able to share with
you
uh because now anytime that i talk about
this game i can just say that
you'd be like full disclosure i'm in the
game which
related i am hosting the official uh
twitch pre and post show i believe
for the night city wire that's airing
tomorrow
i have no idea what's in the night city
wire i'm just as excited as everyone
else's to find out what's in this game
cause i'm hyped about it
uh but that will be on twitch.tv gaming
starts pretty early actually um i am
recording this a couple of days in
advance so i will let you guys know in a
pinned comment
below of the exact details because i
don't have them right now
but i believe this one is mostly focused
on the soundtrack which is something i'm
very excited to learn more about
super cool but yeah that's pretty much
it for me i think i've covered
everything just
um very nice to be able to share this
and have like this weight off where i
can actually finally talk about it
but also to just share my excitement for
how awesome this is
and um just also say the cd projekt red
team
just also seemed excited to work with me
which was really cool they were so
passionate
and excitable and enthusiastic like from
my involvement in this but also the
hands-on previews to just show off their
game
and this studio more than any other
studio that i've had any kind of
relationship with i think
i just feel like want their game to be
perfect so bad they really care about it
being
as perfect as it possibly can be and i
respect the hell out of them for that so
hopefully i didn't screw it up with my
you know media voice acting hopefully
it's wild to me to think that i will be
in the credits for this game
i will be in the credits cyberpunk 2077.
oh my god
also yeah i've had loads of people be
like well i know you said you're not
reviewing the game which i'm still not
doing um but will you be streaming it
look i don't know what i'm doing like a
week from now
but i can't see any reason why i
wouldn't stream the game i don't i just
just full disclosure i don't plan my
streams that far ahead but i imagine
i intend to stream cyberpunk to find
myself in the game to react to that
to have that experience with everyone um
because i just try very hard to share
the things that i feel really positively
about so
yeah definitely intend to do that with
the full disclaimer
that i'm in the goddamn game and very
excited about it it's uh
it's very surreal and i always have to
pinch myself at moments like this like
i've known that i've been in this game
for a while and i've been very excited
about it for a long time but somehow
getting to
tell everyone about it is one of those
moments of just like
damn man i had to save up
to pre-order the witcher 2. i traded in
a bunch of games to get it
i think it came out in 2011 if i
remember correctly it's
just after i graduated high school um
you know i hadn't had a full-time job
and i was so excited i got the full
collector's edition
and thinking of like how that felt and
and how much adoration i had
for cd projekt red
then leading into the witcher 3
where i was already working in games
media i was working for an australian tv
show at that point
and then to now to being in the game is
just like
just [ __ ] surreal and very cool
so yes thank you all for watching this
video
sure a lot of you don't care um for
those of you who do thank you
uh i hope that me at least spreading my
positive vibes
you know help someone i don't i don't
know
i don't know what i'm doing and i will
see you tomorrow morning for the night
city wire i cannot wait
um yeah i'm alana i'll see you guys next
time bye